oui
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans sofico
visionnaire je suis sophie chez vernazza
la population mondiale augmente tout
comme la demande alimentaire serons nous
capables d'approvisionner les habitants
de la planète quand nous serons deux
fois plus nombreux sans détruire
totalement l'environnement nous avons
abordé la question avec l'homme qui a
dévoilé le premier hamburger cultivées
en laboratoire
le professeur en physiologie vasculaire
à l'université de maastricht mark post
[Musique]
monsieur le professeur nous sommes ravis
de vous avoir dans notre émission
aujourd'hui merci j'ai beaucoup de
questions concernant cette viande
certains disent qu'il s'agit de viande
artificielle d'autres que c'est de la
vraie viande commençons par je dirais
que c'est de la vraie
d'accord commençons donc par la question
la plus simple à quoi ressemble le
processus de fabrication de la viande en
laboratoire vous prélever un échantillon
de cellules d'une vache vous la portez
un laboratoire le mettez dans un
bioréacteur lui donner les nutriments et
liquide nécessaire et ensuite
oui
ça prend un échantillon d'une vache et
on extrait des cellules souches de cet
échantillon chaque muscle à des cellules
souches et ils sont là pour réparer les
tissus et elles peuvent proliférer c'est
à dire qu'elles sont capables de se
diviser de nombreuses fois et puis parce
que ce sont des cellules souches
spécifiques du muscle elles savent déjà
comment fabriquer du tissu musculaire
donc vous voulez laisser se multiplier
jusqu'à ce que vous en ayez beaucoup
puis vous les laissez fabriquer ce tissu
et trois semaines plus tard vous
récoltez ce tissu et vous le mettez dans
un hamburger vous prélever un
échantillon n'importe quel muscles ou
d'un muscle en particulier on peut
prélever de n'importe quel muscles oui
comment synthétiser vous les nutriments
je veux dire qu'est-ce qui est utilisé
comme nourriture pour les cellules ce
sont des nutriments naturels ou quelque
chose de synthétique
non ce sont des nutriments naturels
les sucres des acides aminés pour
fabriquer des protéines des vitamines
des minéraux des acides gras voilà ce
sont des ingrédients naturels qui
peuvent être produits à partir des
plantes
je suppose que c'est comme avec de la
nourriture ordinaire quand vous avez des
boeufs ou des coulées dopé aux
antibiotiques pour que les animaux
soient plus beau est plus grand et puis
vous pouvez les élevés en plein air donc
pour parler de votre viande cultivées en
laboratoire dans quelle catégorie se
trouve-t-elle eh bien vous savez
certains la qualifient de viande propre
parce que vous savez exactement ce qu'il
ya dedans vous pouvez le contrôle est
pas d'antibiotiques ni d'autres types
d'ingrédients qui ne doivent pas s'y
trouver
on peut tout contrôler et il n'y a aucun
risque de contamination bien sûr car les
bactéries ne peuvent pas pénétrer dans
le système
je dirais donc que c'est de la viande
biologique mais elle est bien sûr
cultivées en laboratoire et non dans les
champs
est il possible d'influencer ses
qualités gustatives
je veux dire pouvez vous en fait retirer
toutes les substances cancérigènes que
l'on trouve dans la viande ordinaires ou
faire infuser n'importe quelle saveur
oui bien sûr
en ce qui concerne le goût il faut
comprendre que tous les hamburgers que
vous mangez sont aromatisés c'est à dire
que les saveurs ils sont ajouté et nous
allons faire exactement la même chose
vous ajoutez donc une sorte de saveurs
de l'hamburger et c'est ce qu'on fait
déjà avec de la viande ordinaires et
nous allons faire de même il s'agit de
ces mêmes saveurs qui sont utilisés dans
les cuisines du restaurant oui je suis
les fabricants de hamburgers à base de
viande ordinaires
pouvez-vous également ajouté des
vitamines supplémentaire à la viande
pour qu'elle devienne encore meilleurs
et
vous avez parlé de cancer
manger trop de viande comporte deux
risques pour la santé
et le risque de maladie cardiovasculaire
qui provient des acides gras saturés
dans les graisses oui nous prévoyons
bien sûr de fabriquer des tissus adipeux
et ces cellules sont capables de
produire des acides gras insaturés dons
c'est possible
et quand nous trouverons un moyen de
faire cela la viande sera meilleur pour
votre santé
notre risque qui a légèrement accru avec
la viande ordinaires si vous en mangez
beaucoup et c'est lui du cancer
colorectal
dans la viande ordinaires
c'est pourquoi l'organisation mondiale
de la santé a recommandé de ne pas
manger plus de 300 grammes de viande
rouge par semaine
qui n'est pas beaucoup ce qui correspond
à peu près à
300 g oui c'est ça
un stock et demi ja oui pour une semaine
entière
de
comprendre le composant de la viande
rouge à l'origine de ce risque élevé de
cancer colorectal reste inconnu et
jacques donc tant que ce n'est pas
vraiment connue nous ne pouvons rien y
faire
l'un des composants incriminés et la
myoglobine
qui rend la viande rouge
[Musique]
c'est la viande rouge qui est associé à
ce risque
heureusement nous pouvons déterminer
exactement la quantité de mios globine
que nous voulons avoir dans cette viande
car cela dépend du niveau d'oxygène
auquel vous la cultiver
existe-t-il un niveau de mieux globine
qui ne présentent aucun risque pour la
santé
oui
je suis d'accord avec cette
recommandation de 300 grammes de viande
rouge par semaine vous n'aimez pas trop
la viande mais pourquoi avez vous décidé
de fabriquer de la viande in vitro si
bien sûr mais je n'ai pas besoin de trop
de viande à 300 g me suffisent
d'accord quand vous avez commencé à
produire ce produit comment cela s'est
il passé vous vous êtes réveillés en
jour et vous vous êtes dit pourquoi ne
pas cultiver de la viande in vitro et la
rendre plus saines ou plus savoureuse
malheureusement ce n'est pas aussi
romantique
est l'idée n'est pas du tout nouvel
wiston churchill il faisait déjà
référence en 1939
c'est en 2004 si je ne me trompe pas
il ya eu un homme aux pays bas qui a
décidé qu'il était temps de passer des
paroles aux actes mais lui-même n'était
pas scientifique
il a donc dû embaucher quelques
scientifiques alors commencé à
travailler là dessus
deux ans plus tard j'ai rejoint ce
projet et eelv a semblé que c'était une
excellente idée surtout pour
l'environnement et qu'il fallait aller
dans ce sens pour les animaux aussi
selon vous une seule cellule pourrait
produire jusqu'à dix mille kilos de
viande cela signifie t'il par exemple
qu'une vache et ferrer pour toute
l'australie comment est ce possible
et bien c'est tout simplement parce que
les cellules ont une énorme capacité de
réplication elles peuvent se diviser
énormément de foi et si vous faites le
calcul nous ne sommes pas encore à ce
stade et puis l'on peut le calculer si
chaque cellule double 40 fois vous aurez
une sorte de courbe exponentielle et
après 40 réplication on aura environ dix
mille kilos de viande
théoriquement on pourrait y arriver dans
combien de temps
est bien le premier type de produits je
pense sera sur le marché dans deux ans
deux ans et demi
je parle de cette situation où une vache
serait suffisante pour un pays
je ne sais pas pour le moment nos
calculs montrent qu'à partir d'un
demi-gramme de tissus prélevés d'une
vache nous pouvons en produire 2000 kg
c'est déjà un grand pas en avant vous
pouvez prélevé plusieurs échantillons
sur une vache mais cela ne veut pas dire
qu'une vache sera suffisante pour toute
l'australie il faut aller plus loin
en fait il ne reste que cinq ou six
duplication de plus pour y arriver
nous ont soumis donc maintenant à 32
ici on parvient à 38 40
nous y serons presque
quand nous parlons de viande de
laboratoire ce ne sont que des
hamburgers pour le moment mais je veux
dire les goûts des gens sont très divers
tout le monde n'aime pas forcément les
hamburgers il préfère les steaks et le
filet ou par exemple un tibbon pouvez
vous fabriquez un tibbon peut-être pas
aujourd'hui mais théoriquement
oui théoriquement c'est possible
pour cultiver de la viande comme celle
que nous fabriquons aujourd'hui la
viande hachée je comptais sur l'auto
organisation de ces cellules afin que
ces cellules puisse fabrique un tissu
vous devez les aider un peu mais ensuite
elles vont créer un tissu elles mêmes
il ya une limite à leur taille pour la
viande hachée c'est bien ça convient
pour les hamburgers et pour les
boulettes de viande et pour faire un
steak il faut encore trois autres choses
la première consiste à imposer une
structure 3d plus grande à ces cellules
autrement elles créeront de petites
formes
c'est donc là que l'impression 3d est
introduite avec les biomatériaux vous
devez cultiver des cellules musculaires
et des cellules adipeuses dans les mêmes
conditions
actuellement elles sont cultivées
séparément
et surtout vous avez besoin d'un système
de canaux pour transférer tous les
nutriments de l'oxygène nécessaire au
bon endroit
c'est pour ça que nous avons des
vaisseaux sanguins
mais pour faire cela avec un produit à
base de viande on aura besoin d'avoir
quelque chose de similaire aux vaisseaux
sanguins pour assurer que tous ces
nutriments et oxygène soit répartie
uniformément dans les tissus en fin de
compte vous allez vous efforcez d'avoir
toutes sortes de produits carnés
cultiver ah oui absolument
voiture en laboratoire une fois que
c'est un burger seront sur le marché
nous commencerons à développer des
steaks
à part le boeuf peut-on faire la même
chose avec du poulet du port ou du
poisson oui et à vrai dire certaines
personnes le font d'autres entreprises
dans le monde travaillent soit sur du
porc reçoit sur du poulet du canard ou
du poisson c'est le même principe
lorsque vous mangez de la vraie viande
vous pouvez choisir un stack argentin
très savoureux où vous pouvez prendre en
simple ce texte vous pouvez voir la
différence parce que leur goût n'est pas
le même si votre laboratoire fabriquer
tout un éventail de produits carnés ses
produits aurait-il tous le même goût
ressemblerait-il tous un steak argentin
par exemple où il y aura également une
gradation
que je considère comme un des avantages
de cette technologie mais peu de gens
voient cela comme un véritable avantage
c'est que vous pouvez avoir un produit
identique à chaque fois vous pouvez le
standardisés et cela semble ennuyeux la
plupart des gens veulent avoir une
certaine stabilité quant à ce qu'ils
achètent au supermarché ici aux pays bas
la viande est comme un sous-produit du
secteur laitier les vaches sont déjà
assez lié quand elles sont abattus pour
fournir de la viande il n'y a aucune
garantie quant à la qualité de notre
viande en argentine oui mais ici au pays
bas ce n'est pas le cas et je ne sais
pas quelle est la situation en russie
et personnellement je déteste ça si je
dépense beaucoup d'argent pour un steak
je veux qu'il soit de bonne qualité cela
ne me dérange pas si je dépense beaucoup
d'argent pour ça je dois être sûr de la
qualité si la viande n'est pas bonne je
suis vraiment déçu je pense donc que la
possibilité de garantir la qualité est
un vrai point positif
on le regarde cultivées in vitro coûte
1000 dollars environ pourquoi est ce si
cher pourquoi c'est tellement cher
qui va l'acheter il ya une bonne raison
à cela
actuellement nous avons recours à une
technologie médicale
donc tous les ingrédients utilisés tels
que les acides aminés les nutriments à
son de qualité pharmaceutique
ils sont faits pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique
et c'est pourquoi c'est vraiment cher
et mais fondamentalement ce n'est que du
sucre et des aminés et quelques
composants naturels donc si vous les
obtenez d'une source différente c'est
pas de source médicale cela deviendrait
beaucoup moins cher
nous devons faire une courte pause avant
de poursuivre notre conversation avec
mark post l'homme qui a dévoilé au monde
le premier hamburger cultivées in vitro
restez avec nous
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour pour poursuivre
notre entretien avec marc poste qui a
créé le premier hamburgers à base de
viande de laboratoire et nous allons
évoquer les perspectives pour l'avenir
quand vous dites que dans les deux ou
trois années à venir ou disons même au
cours de la prochaine décennie la viande
cultivées en laboratoire sera compétitif
sur le marché êtes vous sûr que vous
allez pouvoir la produire en quantité
suffisante pour qu'elle puisse rivaliser
avec la viande ordinaires sur le marché
vous avez raison c'est un défi parce que
c'est une énorme industrie bien sûr
et commencer à construire ses usines et
ses bioréacteur et tout ce genre de
choses sera une grande entreprise
cela reste développer progressivement
elle m'en voyez vous pour arriver à une
acceptation massive par le public et à
la consommation de masse
le prix doit être bas
et les gens doivent adhérer
je pense que nous assisterons à une
période de transition
tant du point de vue de l'adhésion des
consommateurs et du point de vue de la
production et j'espère que ce seront des
processus parallèles
objectif n'est pas de devenir le plus
grand producteur deurne de rigueur au
monde nous avons concédé sous licence
cette technologie à des entreprises qui
construisent ces usines et commence la
production
je me demande aussi pourquoi il faut
aussi longtemps pour que cela soit
disponible pour les gens qui sont prêts
à en consommer d'un autre côté la
production de viande végétalienne est en
plein essor en ce moment la société est
bien le mythe est entré en bourse il ya
un an et est estimé à plus de 13
milliards de dollars me semble-t-il
j'ai goûté un hamburger à base de
viandes fabriquées avec des pois je n'ai
pas pu faire la différence si j'avais su
que ce n'était pas de la vraie viande je
me serais peut-être dit que c'était de
la viande végétalienne mais je n'avais
aucune idée et cela va sembler beau donc
ça existe déjà on peut l'acheter en
manger en goûter mais pour la viande
cultivées en laboratoire on a besoin
d'encore deux ou trois ans ou peut-être
dix ans et s'est toujours produit en
laboratoire pourquoi est-ce si différent
burger je pense que ça va je n'ai jamais
vu un steak approprié fabriqué à partir
d'une protéine texture ise à base de
plantes
très difficile très difficile à faire
pour être honnête je ne pense pas que
cela soit possible
on ne sera pas en mesure de fabriquer
toute une gamme de produits est lié une
entreprise qui développe des produits à
base de plantes comme la mayonnaise et
les et qui s'est lancé dans la culture
de la viande parce qu'ils estiment
également que l'entreprise n'ira pas
loin avec des seuls aliments à base de
plantes ça ne suffira pas
vous pouvez devenir végétarien demain
sans substitut de viande à base de
plantes vous pouvez le faire beaucoup de
gens le font mais c'est une minorité
chiite moins de 5% de la population est
végétarienne du moins pour ce qui est de
la population qui peut se permettre de
manger de la viande
apparemment ça c'est quelque chose qui
est programmée en nous cette envie de
viande et les produits végétariens ne
peuvent pas satisfaire cette envie de la
même manière
d'accord en parlant de la production de
masse de viande de laboratoire c'est là
semble tout à fait réelle est faisable
dans le cas des pays bas ou de n'importe
quel pays européen ou des états unis
mais le marché de la viande est vraiment
en plein essor dans les pays du tiers
monde n'est ce pas
imaginez vous un stand avec de la viande
fabriquer en laboratoire
mais par exemple
et bien bombée est un bon exemple parce
que band est une sorte de grande île de
mangeurs de viande en inde
en inde bien sûr manger du boeuf n'est
pas une chose très courante ils
appellent ça buffle ou quelque chose
comme ça
mais c'est globalement similaire
mais oui l'inde est un peu lente dans ce
domaine la chine y arrive en ce moment
la corée du sud est déjà dans le secteur
depuis longtemps je vois certains pays
qui pourraient mettre cela en place
vous savez en chine elle c'est aussi dû
à l'épidémie de grippe porcine africaine
ces grands pays en développement avec
une importante augmentation de la
consommation de viande dans les trente
prochaines années vont adopter cela j'en
suis sûr
selon vous cela deviendra compatible
avec le marché dans un délai de dix ans
environ
bien sûr mais les gens n'ont pas
toujours envie d'opter pour quelque
chose d'artificiel lorsqu'ils ont
entendu parler pour la première fois
ci nous avons disons hamburgers à base
de viande cultivée in vitro et
hamburgers avec du vrai boeuf et qu'il
coûte le même prix pensez vous que les
gens opteront pour celui à base de
viande artificielle
pourquoi j'ai tellement de stéréotypes
qui doivent être cassé avant que j'opte
pour cela
quant à la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu'ils vont faire ce choix
tous ceux qui mangent de la viande
peut-être pas tout le monde mais
beaucoup de mangeurs de viande ont un
petit problème avec ça parce qu'ils
savent maintenant si vous lisez les
journaux qu'il y à des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre qui sont associées que
les abattoirs ne sont pas les endroits
les plus adaptées il faut tuer des
animaux
franchement notre éthique évolue
progressivement vers le fait de ne plus
sentir à l'aise à face l'idée que des
animaux soient tués pour subvenir à nos
besoins c'est pour ça que les mouvements
végétariens et végétaliens ont émergé et
nous avons toujours réussi en ce viersat
dans les profondeurs de nos consciences
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'alternative
mais une fois qu'un show est apparu ce
n'est soudainement plus possible et vous
devez accepter cela en vous disant ah
oui un animal a été tué pour ça ou s'est
associé à une émission des gaz à effet
de serre or ici nous avons
essentiellement le même produit le même
prix la même qualité sans aucune de ces
problématiques c'est en fait en
laboratoire au début c'est effrayant
mais après ensuite ça ne l'est plus
pensez vous que dans 20 ans 30 ans nous
ne pourront manger devrait hamburger ou
de vrais steak que dans des endroits
vraiment secret et que ce sera
excessivement cher
si une telle possibilité subsistent si
nos gouvernements ne nous interdisent
pas de manger tout cela
rappelez-vous qu'en europe certains
produits alimentaires sa ont été retirés
du marché à cause du bien-être animal
le foie gras par exemple est interdit à
manhattan le foie gras la fourrure aussi
les oeufs de poules élevées en cage ne
sont plus autorisés dans l'union
européenne
uniquement en fonction du bien-être
animal donc à un moment donné lorsque
vous avez une alternative crédible les
agences de régulation où les
gouvernements ont tendance à intervenir
et à dire eh bien désormais nous ne
permettrons plus là
mais doit-on dire aux gens qu'ils
devraient faire de leur mieux
puisque les gens ont toujours envie de
tout ce qui est naturel que ce soit du
bois du cuir des aliments biologiques
peu importe quand ils entendent viande
de laboratoire aux états unis il
l'appelle franken mythe et ce n'est pas
du tout flatteur mais en ce moment c'est
bien le cas
ce qui est historiquement correct
d'accord je veux bien vous croire sur
parole
mais c'est comme ça qu'on la qualifie de
nos jours donc comment se débarrasser de
ce genre de clichés envers la viande de
laboratoire qui doit s'en charger vous
monsieur le professeur ou peut-être le
président américain où le président
russe et bien cela va être
si vous regardez des études de marché
bien que ce soit encore un peu
préliminaire
l'acceptation de ce type d'aliment
augmente
on seulement aux états unis mais aussi
en europe en inde en chine environ 50%
des gens disent oui nous voyons cela
arriver et nous acceptons cette
évolution
cela ne signifie pas qu'ils achèteront
au supermarché c'est une autre chose il
faudra un peu de marketing vous savez du
récit
il faudra peut-être des petites unités
de production de type micro brasserie
que vous pourrez visiter le dimanche et
où vous pourrez voir comment ces
produits
il faut se familiariser avec ce
processus
il y a besoin d'une campagne
d'information c'est ça oui mais vous
savez il y un bon exemple aux pays bas
vous ne le savez probablement pas mais
nous avons une saucisse ici aux pays bas
qui s'appelle fricandelles je sais ce
que c'est que l'africain d'elle d'accord
je n'en mange pas mais je sais ce que
c'est eh bien nous on avoue une variante
spécifique ici aux pays bas et en
belgique et c'est un plat très très
populaire personne ne sait ce qu'il ya
dedans personne ne veut savoir ce qu'il
contient même vous si je sais ce qu'il
ya dedans qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans
en fait c'est un produit tout à fait
convenable il n'y a rien de
problématique
le fait est qu'il y à toutes sortes
d'histoires atroce quant à ce que ce
produit contient et personne ne veut
vraiment savoir ce qu'il y a nous sommes
donc parfaitement capable de manger des
choses dont nous ne savons pas
exactement comment elles ont été
fabriquées il m'aime ce qu'elles sont
tant que c'est bon
mais tant que c'est bon et tant que vous
développer au fil du temps et cela prend
du temps une confiance envers ce produit
parce que vous voyez d'autres personnes
ont mangé et vous voyez qu'elles vont
bien et finalement
nous sommes biologiquement programmés
pour ne pas manger des choses que nous
ne connaissons pas si vous allez dans la
forêt que vous cueillez des champignons
que vous en faites une soupe et qui vous
ne savez pas ce que vous faites je vous
avais 95% de chances de vous empoisonner
c'est donc un programme très naturel de
ne pas manger des produits qui ne nous
sont pas familiers avec
chaque nouvel aliment qui arrivent sur
le marché le même problème surgit vous
devez expliquer ce que c'est le rendre
appétissant quelque sorte
et puis bien sûr s'il y a une belle
histoire à raconter
les gens vont commencer à considérer ça
comme une excellente idée et accepter
l'idée de le manger
et le reste suivra
[Musique]
dernière question pensez vous que si
cela prend son envol ce qui est très
probable
les agriculteurs seront ils complètement
privés de travail je veux dire ça
commence avec la viande mais ensuite ça
va toucher les produits laitiers oui
absolument parce qu'on enlève du lait
aux veaux pour faire du fromage cela
veut dire qu'il n'y aura plus
d'agriculteurs à l'avenir c'est ça non
on ira peut-être pas autant d'éleveurs
de bovins ou de producteurs laitiers
j'espère qu'il y aura encore des
agriculteurs qui fabriquent tous les
ingrédients pour faire produire notre
viande
les ingrédients proviennent de poids de
maïs doublé de soja et ils doivent
encore être cultivée
les agriculteurs sont des entrepreneurs
ce qu'ils font principalement c'est
exploiter la valeur de leurs terres mon
voisin était éleveur de porcs et il ne
pouvait plus gagner d'argent avec des
porcs il est passé aux pommes de terre
ils utilisent donc maintenant ses terres
pour cultiver des pommes de terre et il
aime encore plus ses pommes de terre que
ces cochons car elle lui apporte de
l'argent
et vous n'avez pas à les tuer
et vous n'avez pas les tuer et en plus
vous n'avez pas toutes ces odeurs et il
ya beaucoup davantage vous savez j'ai
rencontré 400 éleveurs de porcs au
minnesota cet hiver
il examinait tous les photos de ces
bioréacteur dans une pièce bien chauffé
et il pensait à la veille où ils
pelletey le fumier par -20
quel travail est le plus agréable
moi je suis d'accord monsieur le
professeur merci beaucoup pour cet
aperçu merci et bonne chance dans toutes
vos entreprises j'espère qu'on se
reverra bientôt pour que je puisse enfin
goûté cet hamburger parce que pour le
moment ce n'est pas possible non je sais
qu'il se trouve ici dans votre labo mais
je ne peux pas y goûter non
malheureusement
[Musique]